what's going on guys today i'm going to
explain every female titan in the
history of attack on titan
this shifter arguably had the most
terrifying introduction to the series
as she sprinted onto our screens and
just began butchering people left and
right
except for armin of course in this video
i'll be breaking down the full backstory
of the female titan we know as well as
explaining its true power
and commenting on the design of ancient
female titans from the past
however before we begin i felt i should
give my take on that classic question
of whether or not a man can inherit the
female titan in my opinion i definitely
think a male could receive this shifter
but it would probably end up looking
like a skinless version of the attack
titan
it's important to remember that all of
the nine shifters are derived from
yamir's original founding titan and
therefore any of the nine can be
inherited by yemiya's descendants
given that she is the direct ancestor of
every ld we've seen in the series with a
few exceptions
it means that any subject of ymir
whether they be male or female
would be able to inherit this shifter if
they were to eat any spine
after all the female only has this name
because it displays feminine features
when a woman controls it
unlike the draw titan and cart titan
which appeared gender neutral even when
possessed by women
the founder is the only other shifter
known to have melons throughout
different points in history
but its gender has never been its
defining feature the female on the other
hand doesn't have an obvious power or
history that would make you call it a
different name
i mean the people on parodies just
happened to call it the female titan
because it looked like a woman
and by pure coincidence that was always
its official title
anyway moving on to its long list of
abilities in order to fully explain this
titan's potential i will be talking
about manga spoilers
so if you don't want to know anything
from the second half of the final season
then pause the video now
for the rest of you let's get into the
details and the first power i want to
talk about is the female titan's hybrid
ability
in chapter 133 of the manga it was
confirmed that certain shifters can
manifest the abilities of others
once they consume a part of that other
titan perhaps the most famous example
was when the draw titan gained the
characteristics and the memories of the
beast titan
after consuming just a single drop of
zeke's spinal fluid according to annie
it's especially easy for the female
titan to do the same thing which is why
marley made her eat all sorts of body
parts before the mission on paradise
possibly as a result of those
experiments the current female titan has
powers similar to other shifters
such as her titan crystallization aaron
stated that annie's crystal was
identical to that of the warhammers and
it's still something that only these two
titans have been shown to do
while it is plausible that maybe the
female titan had this ability regardless
we can't rule out the fact that the
tigers might have donated a sample of
the warhammer
if requested to do so by mali only the
tiniest piece would be needed for the
female titan to start manifesting new
abilities
so the tigers could have helped out
while still keeping the identity of the
warmer titan a secret
another power of the female titan is its
scream and this version has both
benefits and drawbacks when compared to
zeke
the benefit is that annie's scream
literally works on any pure titan
and allows her to control them to an
extent whereas zeke scream only works on
aliens that have consumed his spinal
fluid
this means the female can affect a
larger amount of pure titans
but unlike the beast she can't create
them nor can she give them detailed
instructions on what to do
as far as we've seen any screen will
simply make them go towards her
and if they get the chance then they
will just eat the female titan's body
such an ability is useful for escaping
situations where the female's body is
trapped
or it can be used to assemble an army of
pure titans which she can then lead into
battle
the first time she did this was during
the day they broke the walls down
as it was annie that gathered the titans
outside wilmaria in the first place
the second time was when she led a horde
of titans to attack the survey corps
however a large portion of that
encounter happened mostly off-screen
extra talents of the female titan
include its endurance which is probably
the best of the nine shifters besides
the car titan
her sprinting speed is also phenomenal
not to mention her precise regeneration
hardening and agility which we saw on
full display during season
1. with that said let's get into the
backstory of annie
followed by a look at the ancient female
titans from history don't forget to hit
that sub button if you haven't already
because next week i will be doing a
video on every colossal titan as well
okay so annie's place of birth is not
confirmed but based on context we can
assume that it was somewhere on the
marlin continent
we know for a fact that she was not born
inside the internment zone as her mother
was just a regular person who lived
outside the walls of liberio
annie was the result of an affair
between her mother and an elden man
so once a butt has confirmed she was an
aldian she was sent to liberia where she
was adopted by mr leonhardt
mr leonhart had a similar story to annie
in that he was from another country but
was sent to the internal zone in mali
once his elden blood was revealed
his goal in adopting her was to turn her
into a warrior which would grant him the
status of honorary marlian and as we
know that brings a lot of benefits
including better medical care
for eldians living in mali it doesn't
get much better than that so from a
young age he would aggressively teach
annie fighting techniques from his
homeland
at this point mr leonhart was simply
using her as a tool to achieve a better
life
and he didn't truly value her as a
daughter as a result her childhood was
pretty crappy
so once she did become strong enough she
beat him so badly that he couldn't walk
straight for the rest of his life
this is why he's often seen with a
walking stick but at the time she beat
him up he was actually happy
because it proved she'd become the
ultimate soldier after this annie became
an isolated person with no regard for
life
and we see this play out during her time
as a warrior candidate since she rarely
socialized with the group
and spent time squashing bugs when she
eventually became the female titan
she was regarded by mali as the perfect
warrior as she used her extensive
fighting techniques to destroy enemy
nations
over the next two years they would feed
her body parts from other titans
which possibly led to her inheriting new
abilities like we mentioned earlier
on the morning of the parodies island
operation mr leonhart finally apologized
given that he knew there was a good
chance and he would never return in this
moment he acknowledged that everything
he did to her was wrong
and that his status as an honorary
marlin meant nothing if she didn't come
back
he made her promise to one day return to
mali and this had a profound
impact on the rest of the series as
annie went from not caring about
anything
to them being motivated to return home
we saw this early on in the mission
where after marcel's death she was the
one saying they should immediately
return back to mali
although reiner did manage to convince
them to continue it was annie who was
the most proactive in trying to actually
complete the mission and go home
she went above and beyond by going
undercover within the walls as she
followed members of the military police
in the hope that it would lead her
closer to the royal family at this point
in time the warriors assumed that the
royal family had the founding titan
which is why she was going out of her
way to do this
after her close encounter with kenny
ackerman she again argued that they
should return to mali
but was overruled by reiner in this very
important scene this scene is a lot more
crucial than i think a lot of people
realize
but in order to explain it we need to
remember one thing
even after aaron was revealed to be a
shifter none of the warriors thought he
had the founding titan
in fact this was only confirmed at the
end of season 2. as far as they knew
the founding titan was still in
possession of the royal family and aaron
simply had the missing attack titan that
marley failed to capture
so the question then becomes if they
didn't think he had the founder
why did annie go out of her way to
capture him instead of trying to
complete the actual mission
in my opinion all goes back to this
conversation as she is clearly ready to
return to mali after five long years on
the island
despite that reiner insisted would be
pointless to go back with nothing to
show for it
rather than trying to retake the founder
annie had basically given up on the main
plan
and was trying to get aaron instead so
she could fulfill what rhino was saying
here
by acquiring the missing attack titan it
was at least something they could use to
maybe claim
that the mission was not a complete
failure if they had caught eren
annie would have been able to return
home to her father and possibly live out
the remaining year she has left
that's why she was crying after her
defeat because she knew she wouldn't be
able to fulfill the promise to return
next up we'll be looking at the ancient
female titans from the past
but bear in mind there will be major
spoilers ahead so if you're an anime
only and you haven't paused already
then now is definitely the time to do so
the first ancient titan we should talk
about is the screaming one
which was brought back to life and
immediately tried to kill reiner this
shifter was similar to annie's design
in that it had virtually no skin but
some bits of flesh were more lightly
coloured than others
its hollow eyes are a very common
feature among female titans with annie
being one of the few to have her eyes
clearly visible
moving over to the muscular female titan
this one was truly the stuff of
nightmares as it was literally just
flesh from head to toe
even the most skinless of titans usually
have somewhere on their body that
doesn't look like just muscle
but this one breaks that tradition with
its horrifying design could you imagine
how much scary it would have been
if this thing was chasing the cervical
instead of annie's version i think a lot
of us would have had trouble sleeping up
to something like that
chapter 136 showed us a different
shifter that seemed to have the least
amount of exposed flesh of any female
and we also got this other one that had
a really savage look to it something
about this design just gives me bad
vibes
like i feel like it was possibly even
more barbaric than annie was
the first bonafide female titan was also
seen in chapter 122
and possibly later in the manga and her
athletic body type is pretty much
representative
of what we've come to expect in the
background we saw a few other female
titan designs
although these ones didn't really have
much detail to them besides certain
assets on their chest
as always thank you guys for watching
this video on all female titans and
don't forget to drop a like if you want
to see more videos like this
until the next one peace out